if you're an artist or an entrepreneur
and you're having a hard time telling
your story I'm going to share with you
why it's so important on this video and
how to do it hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I
recently got a question from one of my
YouTube subscribers love you guys
Sarah who wrote in the say I'm a
beginner at painting I'm not very public
about it yet and I'm not really
interested in being public because
everyone seems to have 500 questions do
people really have to know the biography
of a painter's life what if their life
was a bad life I'm frustrated because I
hesitate when I cite asking for my bio
so I leave a blank the main reason I
started painting is just because as a
writer I still feel as if I have no
voice but when I paint that feel freedom
I always heard a painting is worth a
thousand words and they're right but I
don't think people should know about
someone's crappy past any advice would
be good is it okay to leave a blank or
can I type up a short version of the
happy moments Sarah this is a fantastic
question and I feel your pain in writing
it and the frustration that you feel and
that you want your business to be
successful and you feel like the know
the Bayeux is an important part of it
you don't know what to put in there the
reason why I bio is so important is
because it helps people make a personal
connection to you but people like buying
from entrepreneurs because they feel
like they're buying from that person and
not just buying from a company and your
story can make the difference between
somebody wanted to buy your art and
somebody just passing it over an example
is a buddy of mine fan of the channel
Pete Elvidge who is a pixel artist and
he creates pixel artwork and he did one
of me as being a Minecraft character and
what's great about Pete is not
necessarily his art skills right he's
getting better he wants to have more
shows he wants to get more sales as his
technique still needs to be refined but
it's his story
what makes Pete greatest he's almost
blind so here's his artist who's making
art which is very visual right and he's
completely blind in one eye and almost
completely blind in the other eye and he
uses that remaining vision that he has
to create pixel art and so even though I
think his art could be better and he's
getting better at
technique and training and working on it
I'm interested in him because of his
story that's what your story does it
helps people connect the art to you now
I think one of the things you have to
get past is you only need to tell the
positive happy moments in your life if
you look at a lot of artist lives
they're not fantastic and some of the
greatest art whether it's paintings or
music or poems came out of periods in
their lives of severe depression anger
upsetness and they funneled that energy
into their art you don't have to just
tell all the good stuff what people want
to know is what went into this artwork
who are you and why are you making these
paintings even being honest in your bio
and saying things that you come alive
when you're painting and you're not
great at writing is an honest truthful
statement that will help make people
connect to you so I'd start with
thinking about why you love painting
write it down and try to get a few
sentences out there about your passion
for painting then I think about how it
makes you feel how does it make you come
alive what stresses that relief from
your life if for example the rest of the
world kind of stresses you out and and
you don't feel like you belong and
painting is the only thing that makes
you come alive then right that put that
down in there right I want to feel that
emotional connection to you you can
write about some of your favorite pieces
the ones that really mean something to
you and how you came up with the
inspiration for them you could talk
about your friends and your family and
how you got into it and if they support
you or if they don't support you and how
you continue to persevere regardless
people don't want to just hear the story
about how great things are do you want
to hear the struggle they want to be
able to relate to you and see themselves
in you nobody has a perfect life and if
that's the goods that you're selling
then it's not going to be authentic and
you'll actually lose people to people
who you watch on youtube or read their
BIOS and really follow other ones who
are honest and authentic and vulnerable
and willing to share that because it
opens them up and allows people to
connect with them on a much deeper level
and that's what you want whether you're
an artist or a regular entrepreneur you
want people to feel connected to you and
what you're doing and make it feel like
they're a part of
your story and your journey and they
want to see where you go with it if
after all that you're still super
private and don't want that information
to get out there then what I'd suggest
is using an alias tell your story in a
way that nobody could pinpoint it that
it being actually you but also getting
it out there on their fake name so that
people can feel like they're connected
to the artist the other side benefit
that I think about when I help share my
story is that it could serve as an
inspiration to others if for example you
feel lost in the regular world and art
helps you escape that and makes you feel
happy that could be a solution for
somebody else who is going through the
same thing in their life they might feel
totally lost and helpless and have
nobody in their life to guide them and
by reading your bio and looking at your
art may inspire them to get into art and
to have a happier life having a great
bio and telling your story will help you
get more customers help you have a much
bigger impact help you make more money
and help you have your art to be more
well-known which i think is ideally what
you want so good luck
write that bio from the heart and
believe for those who are watching I'd
love to know your thoughts on writing
the bio any struggles you've had how you
came up with your bio what you feel
really works in your bio as well as what
you like from other people and how they
express themselves and other people
might be able to learn from as well
leave that in the comments below I'm
going to join the discussion I look
forward to seeing what you're right and
of course if you like this video and you
want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon